well i wanted to ask though about your
son does he get mad at you no no it's
crazy you know what's crazy is there was
one joke i did it was like six years ago
before i did live from seattle the
deodorant
no he didn't mind that one it was the
other one and uh
about down here i remember that one and
i was so nervous because i did it in
front of him
and i got off stage and the crowd went
crazy the crowd went crazy when i did
that joke and uh
can you say what it is or you don't want
to say what it is he just talks about
why it isn't that big yet
okay it's in one of your specials yeah
and i finally did a special but but when
i was doing it it was only on him i was
only doing it on him and i was closing
it with it and i would walk off stage
and i could tell my son was just like
not really like he was like good job but
he wasn't really like
yeah like how he usually hugs me and
embrace me like that and then he didn't
appreciate you talking about the lack of
dick size yes and when i when i figured
out was
i needed to make sure that i made fun of
myself more
so that he would be more secure with me
talking about him
and so that's what i did but also
to i switched it to where i i
he delivers the line to me and then i
make fun of me
get it no tell me so like he the
question was about that i don't want to
sit why i don't know i just don't feel
like talking about he talks about his
penis when he was a kid and then and
then what i do is i talk about me your
penis yeah and that's the joke
do you have to clear it with him before
like when you do drugs like that when i
did uh coming in hot the hawaii one i
literally was not gonna do the joke
until he goes dad you have to do that
joke
but we do the same thing you know if i
do something that is gonna don't i clear
it with you yeah and especially with mom
because most of your
um act is about mom and i know you clear
it with her first i hear that all the
time yeah always i do but it's hard but
but when they accept it and when they go
it's a joke like your son did
that's the ultimate check mark for they
have a good sense of humor yeah because
it's done in a good sense of humor yeah
and now my son's like so secure so now
it's like
he wants me to do more stuff like that
so what you're saying is his dick grew
no it's still the same but he is so
secure with it but our accounts grew
yeah
so it's getting him more girls yes it's
such a great now
i don't know
can we move this picture can we do a
different picture okay it's just there's
a what what do you want to see i'll put
up a picture of anything you want a
picture of like i i don't mind that
there's just uh there's like yes well no
or like one of me and howie or something
you want another picture of me and howie
this is most people hopefully you're
listening to this just your son is a
very handsome man he's still here he
must get the how old is he now he's 18
now so he's kind of he's doing this
thing where he models for this thing
called los angeles apparel
and uh for this thing called los angeles
apparel that's a big company yeah
they're a huge company and he's been
doing it and he loves it he's got his
own paychecks now
is that does he want to be in this in
this business i think he wants to do
comedy howie honestly i really i think
he has a good sense of humor
really really good sense
and his timing is amazing it's very
sharp has he been on stage doing it on
his own at all no i bring him on stage
and i i've seen that yes we go back and
forth and uh
i make fun of him basically but
it's so good how he takes it he's so
good so when does he are we close to
seeing i hope i don't know i asked him
last night because i did the uh i did uh
the improv last night and you shoulda
came man nobody called me
dad don't lie yeah you're a liar dude
you wouldn't go anyways he won't go into
really nervous
[Music]